[Applaudissements]
devenir athlètes de haut niveau après 40
ans sans jamais avoir fait vraiment de
sport avant est ce possible
j'ai 50 ans et j'ai commencé à courir
pour mes 40 ans tout a commencé le 31
décembre 2009 lors de la fête du
réveillon du nouvel an lorsqu'un ami me
propose de l'accompagner pour courir un
marathon avec lui au début j'étais pas
trop motivés mais avec l'aide du
champagne et parce que cette course se
court et le jour de mes 40 ans je lui
dis ok je serai avec toi au départ de ce
marathon
sauf que j'avais pas vraiment mesuré
qu'un marathon c'était long de 42 km 195
alors le 2 janvier j'ai commencé à me
préparer
j'ai tout d'abord pris des plans
d'entraînement sur internet
et puis j'ai partagé l'expérience de
coureurs déjà expérimenté globalement
tout s'est bien passé puisque quatre
mois plus tard j'ai couru ce marathon en
2 heures 54 soit environ 15 kilomètres
heure c'est la vitesse moyenne d'un
cycliste régulier ce courir ce marathon
a vraiment été une source d'énergie
j'ai vraiment eu le sentiment de vivre à
nouveau voir même de renaître
moi qui avais la croyance qu après 40
ans j'attendrai que les années passent
jusqu'à ma retraite j'ai été comblé
tout d'abord j'ai pris plaisir à me
préparer et puis et puis tout s'est bien
déroulé par la suite
en fait j'ai pris ma vie en main et j'ai
été comblé c'est vraiment ce que je
voudrais partager avec vous aujourd'hui
que vous prenez conscience que vous êtes
acteur de vos vies et que cela puisse
vous permettent de le devenir ensuite
comme à l'arrivée des marathons j'étais
fatigué mais pas complètement épuisé
j'ai choisi de prendre le départ d'une
course plus longue
un trail
ou course nature de 76 km c'était la
grande course des templiers
j'ai terminé deuxième et j'ai été repéré
par le sélectionneur de l'équipe de
france qui m'a proposé de faire partie
de son équipe
je savais même pas que ça existait et du
coup j'ai pris j'ai pris plaisir à
courir au sein de l'équipe de france
j'ai appris à courir avec des athlètes
j'ai découvert aussi la notion d' équipe
et j'ai préparé ce le premier
championnat du monde de trail qui se
courait en 2013 courir pour l'équipe de
france m'a apporté une grande motivation
et une détermination plus importante que
sur les autres courses j'ai remporté ces
championnats du monde et j'ai vécu là
aussi une nouvelle montée d'émotion et
de découverte de moi même les
spectateurs me disais allez la france
et moi j'étais fier de donner le
meilleur de moi-même pour porter haut
les couleurs de mon drapeau mois qu'il
ne pas me pensais pas patrick patriotes
et puis en fait j'étais tellement
concentrée sur ma course que je ne
voyais pas mes enfants qui
m'encourageait sur le côté il y a bien
eu la culpabilité de la maman après coup
mais surtout je me suis et ont rendu
compte de ma capacité à me concentrer
sur un objectif qu'ils avaient de
l'importance pour moi là aussi lorsqu'on
a des projets il faut vraiment rester
concentré être focus sur l'objectif pour
arriver à son but
et puis pour repousser encore plus loin
mes limites
j'ai choisi de prendre le départ de la
diagonale des fous
la traversée de l'île de la réunion
c'est un ultra trail qui mesure 170 km
et qui présente 11000 mètres de dénivelé
positif et négatif ce qui représente
pour
cyclistes 11 fois la montée et la
descente de l'alpe d'huez ou pour les
parisiens quarante fois la montée et la
descente de la tour eiffel jusqu'au
troisième étage c'est les 276 mètres qui
permettent d'atteindre 2 3e étage et
donc pour courir cette c'est cette
distance je me suis là aussi de nouveau
entraîné et mis en place un programme
bien spécifique et donc j'ai remporté
cette course en 29 eur et j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir c'est une vraie
révélation
le fait de courir longtemps en nature la
beauté des paysages la solitude et la
reconnexion avec moi même c'était
vraiment magique
il y a eu aussi ma victoire sur l'utmb
que j'ai remportée en 25 heures c'est
l'ultra trail le plus connu au monde
dans le même format que celui de la
réunion et courir ainsi 25 à 30 heures
non stop en nature sans m'arrêter
ni pour m'asseoir ni pour manger ni pour
dormir était vraiment une un dépassement
de moi même et une réelle aventure j'ai
j'ai pu ainsi dépassé et repousser mes
limites et c'est ainsi c'est ainsi que
que j'ai découvert encore plus de
potentiel
je devais pour gagner la rive est le
plus vite possible je ne pouvais pas
m'autoriser à m'arrêter et je te vais
toujours être en mouvement
il en est de même pour vos projets être
actif et mener des actions les unes
après les autres pour atteindre votre
but est indispensable maintenant je vais
vous parler du pouvoir de mon mental et
notamment de la visualisation
c'est un outil que j'ai particulièrement
utilisé
car avant le départ d'une course jeu sur
la ligne de départ je ne partais pas
pour une compétition et encore moins
pour la gagner mais surtout pour vivre
une aventure je m'entraînais
sérieusement 15 à 20 heures par semaine
physiquement et mentalement une à cinq
heures par semaine pendant ses
entraînements manteau je me répétais mon
parcours de compétition
je me voyais réussir est passé la ligne
d'arrivée j'étais convaincu que tout se
réalisera d'une façon parfaite sur la
ligne de départ je n'avais aucun doute
sur mes capacités
c'est ainsi que pendant les
entraînements mentaux je répétais des
dizaines de fois le parcours mentalement
avant de ré le réaliser physiquement le
jour de l'épreuve
ces entraînements manteau m'ont
tellement apporté aimons tellement
persuadés de mes capacités que bien que
j'habite en sarthe en plaine avec
seulement des côtes de 50 mètres de
déclivité
j'ai réussi à remporter des victoires
avec plus de 11 km de montées et
descentes
j'ai aussi détourner les carnets
d'entraînement qu'ils sont bien connus
par les sportifs en carnet de vie j
consigny j consigne est tout ce qui
concernait mes entraînements sportifs
mais également mais ma vie
professionnelle parce que je travaillais
à 80% et mes loisirs en famille très
rapidement j'ai pu observer que je des
grandes lignes sont dégagées j'ai pu
ainsi établir une routine de préparation
est également un rétroplanning la
répétition de chaque séquence me
permettait d'assurer une qualité de mes
entraînements et
être sûr d'arriver au top pour le jour j
j consigne est également mes ressentis
ce qui m'a permis de percevoir comment
mes émotions avait de l'affluence sur
mes actions pour être acteurs de ces
projets il faut toujours être en
mouvement et je vous invite aussi à
travailler particulièrement votre mental
vous verrez c'est un outil très puissant
qu'on néglige souvent alors en synthèse
est il possible de devenir sportive de
haut niveau
après 40 ans eh bien j'ai envie de vous
dire oui puisque j'en suis la preuve
vivante
j'ai pu aborder avec vous de façon pour
moi de là tant gens ce qu'ils sont les
équilibres de l'homme avec la nature et
également l' équilibre de mon physique
avec mon mental et pour conclure je
dirais que j'ai abordé la course comme
un défi et ce soir là en fait
en m'engageant ça a complètement
bouleversé ma vie est aussi celle de ma
famille puisque en fait on a parcouru la
planète en ckd coin et on a vécu des
aventures formidable en m'ouvrant à ce
nouveau domaine de la course à pied j'ai
découvert que j'avais du potentiel et je
me suis enrichi de nouvelles
connaissances et j'aime à dire du haut
de mon à m 54 que je grandis encore tous
les jours
grâce à ce que j'en prends à ce que
j'apprends et parce que je transmets je
vous invite vous aussi à vous ouvrir à
tous ceux que la vie pourra vous
apporter et à vous enrichir de nouvelles
connaissances voire même de nouvelles
compétences
enfin je partagerai avec vous deux
citations celle de mark twain qui dit il
ne savait pas que c'était impossible
alors ils l'ont fait et aussi
citation extraite du film forrest gump
la vie c'est comme une boîte de
chocolats on ne sait jamais sur quoi on
va tomber
merci
[Applaudissements]